all right my favorite restaurants are
breakfast joints and there is a new one
opening up can't wait to try it the
Broken Yolk Cafe is launching its second
location in southern Nevada that happens
Monday in Henderson here to talk more
about it is Nikki SackMan thanks for
being here hi thank you for having me
this is a San Diego operation in fact
you're from San Diego but the one in
Town Square right correct is very
successful I've heard great things about
it yes yes it's uh definitely a very
successful store and you know we're
looking to expand so that's why we're
opening up in Henderson right in
Henderson where in Henderson do you know
yeah it is at 3458 Saint Rose Parkway at
the corner of Maryland and St Rose
excellent and that happens next Monday
yes so is there a grand opening event
yeah yeah we have a grand opening uh we
open at 7 A.M and you know you can have
some of our delicious food that we have
displayed here we have a pretty
extensive menu the great thing about the
Broken Yolk is that there's something
for everybody so we have you know
several breakfast Classics as well as
our take on Innovative brunch dishes
um and I can walk you through something
yeah let's talk about some of these yeah
so um as I said we have something for
everybody so over here you have our
spicy vegan Bowl which is 100 vegan made
with just eggs and Beyond sausage and
moving over here is our um sweet Trio
which is a sampling of our favorite
Sweet Treats so I'm sampling the Beyonce
yeah tell me what you think yeah and uh
this is our Tiki toast which we're known
for it's made with King's Hawaiian bread
and then the crunchy French toast which
is French toast with frosted flakes and
then oh that sounds delicious that's my
favorite one that sounds it tastes like
a jelly donut it's you'll have to take a
bite and then this is the Cinna cake
which is our take on a cinnamon roll
pancake and then over here is our Golden
State Benedict which is a California
twist you know we have those San Diego
Roots so on an eggs benedict and what's
brunch without a couple of drinks so we
offer Mimosa flights as well I love this
I've seen this done with coffee I've not
seen this done with mimosas oh well yeah
you got to go to a Broken Yolk no that's
great yeah and the great thing about the
Henderson location is that has a fully
stocked bar so they'll be serving your
breakfast your favorite brunch cocktails
as well as these delicious five o'clock
somewhere it really is yeah
the fake sausage I know there's a better
name for it it's actually really good
yeah yeah we definitely try our best to
cater to you know as many people as
possible so vegans vegetarians
gluten-free like you name it you know
our menu is so wide so what's one of the
more popular items that people seem to
go to yeah um Golden State Benedict is
definitely always on the top I
personally love the Border Benedict
which is a southern twist South of the
Border twist that has a corn cake with
our poblano sauce it's delicious and
it's an expensive it sounds phenomenal
all right next Monday in Henderson in
the meantime people can go to Town
Square yeah definitely all right the
Broken Yolk Nikki thanks for being